DAVID RIPHAGEN:
Welcome, and thank you
for joining our breakout
session on playing fair.
I'm David.
I'm a product manager
with Google Play Commerce.
I'm responsible for user trust.
And the last year,
Jonathan and I
have been working
together closely
with a lot of
developers thinking
about how we would create a
more fair and balanced platform
for your apps and your games.
JOHN MCGUIRE: Thanks, David.
Hi, everyone.
My name is John McGuire, and I'm
a partner development manager
here at Google Play.
And David and I are really
excited to come talk
to you about the
ways that we can make
developing for Android better.
So we titled this
talk Playing Fair.
And part of this
means maintaining
a fair in-game
economy in your games
so you can build sustainable,
long-term businesses
on our platform.
So that's the
general topic of what
we're going to cover today.
So now I'll go into the agenda.
So briefly, I'm going to
talk about what playing
fair means for Google Play.
And then I'm going to
hand it over to David,
and he's going to talk
about a really cool product
announcement we have today.
But we're actually going to
spend most of the time talking
with you, the developers.
So we have two developers here
we're going to invite on stage,
and we're going to engage
in a fireside chat format
with a discussion on what
playing fair means to them,
their principles, their
priorities, their challenges.
And then if we have
some time at the end,
we'll save it for you
guys to ask us some Q&A,
but nothing too hard.
So when we started down
the path of playing fair,
we started with two main goals.
The first was that we wanted
a balanced in-app purchase
economy.
So if you think about
when you have a game
and you have a
currency in your game,
users pay money
for that currency.
And so you're assigning
a monetary value
to that currency.
And we want you to be
able to preserve this
so you control that and you
have full control over that.
So that was the first
objective that we have.
The second thing is
that we want to do
the right thing for all users.
And this means that
for good users,
we want to provide a fair
and rewarding experience
on our platform.
But we also, importantly,
want to deter the bad users.
And so when we combine
those two objectives,
we hope that we can
achieve wins for you,
the developers, the users,
and us as Google Play.
So let me talk
about our principles
to help us achieve these goals.
The first is that we want to do
the right thing for all users
all the time.
And this sounds like a really
big, googly, lofty goal.
But really, it
starts with assuming
that all users and all
developers are inherently good.
And we really believe that.
And so when they're
inherently good,
we can provide them access
to all of our services.
And that's a really
important trait to us.
But we know from experience,
and probably you do, too,
that not all users are good.
And there's a very
small minority of them
that aren't good.
And so we have to
evaluate everything
on a case-by-case basis or
an interaction-by-interaction
basis.
And to highlight this, let
me bring up an example.
So who here in the audience has
made an in-app purchase before?
That's a good showing.
I know I have myself.
And so let's assume that you
give a developer some money,
and in turn, you get
in-game currency.
Let's call them coins.
Now let's suppose you want
to refund for your purchase.
Well, in today's in-app purchase
world, you get your money back.
But you also keep your coins,
which is a little bit weird.
When you think about that
in the physical world,
that would be like
going to buy a vacuum
and wanting to return the
vacuum and get a refund,
but actually keeping the vacuum.
And that's a little bit weird.
And so when you think about a
good user who wants a refund,
we believe that they should
be willing to give up
their in-game currency
to get their money back.
Now we think about the bad user.
And they might not want
to give up their currency,
but it's still the
right thing to do.
And so in all cases, both the
good user and the bad user,
giving up the currency
is the right thing to do.
And we believe that.
So we took these two principles,
and we combined them together,
and we built an API.
And the API will allow
you, the developer,
to access all of your
refunds for your games
so that you can take back
the currency from the users,
whether they're
good or they're bad,
and make your game
more balanced.
And that's the big product
announcement we have today.
So I'm going to hand it
over to David for him
to talk more about this.
DAVID RIPHAGEN: Thanks, John.
So it's 2:30.
We're in the basement, and
we're going to talk APIs.
Cool.
Yes.
So what I'm going
to do-- I'm going
to talk a little bit about
how generic this API works.
Then I'm going to give
you some examples.
We've been piloted for
about 10, 12 months now.
And then I'm also
going to give you
some examples about how some
of the developers we work with
have actually implemented this
and made huge, huge games.
So I'll do a lot
of simplifications.
If you have any questions,
go find John or me afterwards
and talk to us.
So the first thing we
did is we started looking
at all the refunded orders.
So these are orders that
either we gave a refund for
or that the bank has
given a chargeback on.
And we were trying
to think about
how can we get our developers
to know about these orders
so you can actually take that
physical vacuum cleaner back.
So what we did is we--
actually, let me just
walk you through an example.
So what we did is we looked
at all the refunded orders.
A user comes into Google Play,
maybe made a $10 purchase
for 10,000 coins.
If we approve a refund
there, what we do now
is we store those orders
in a voided order table.
So these orders are labeled as
in do not deliver or claw back.
With the API, what you
can do as a developer--
you can call this API.
It's called the
Voided Purchases API.
You can receive the
data on that order,
and you can then
claw back the item.
So what happens is the user
gets their refund approved.
They get their $10.
But once you call that API
and you have that order,
you can take the
10,000 gems back.
So we learned that this
works really, really
well for refunds.
And I have a next
slide on impact.
So we extended it to other
types of orders as well.
We looked at cancellations.
We looked at banks or issuers
giving chargebacks out,
and we added those as well.
And this works really, really,
really well for bad users.
It also works well
for good users.
Because we believe
that as a good user,
you're OK getting
back to your money
and willing to give up the coins
that you purchased with it.
So here's the impact slide.
We've been piloting this
for about 10 to 12 months
with a couple of
different developers.
We've seen really, really
big impact everywhere.
So on average, we see refunds
decrease with more than 60%
in about two to
three months' time.
So what happens is it takes
time for the community,
and especially for
abusers, to find out
that this abuse factor is gone.
So now we get into a
little bit more details.
Because of course,
you want to know
how can I do this for my game.
So this is an Early Access API.
So you have to sign up, and
we'll show you a link later on.
And we'll also send you
the detailed documentation
so you don't have to
take pictures of this.
But broadly, how it
works is you give us
the start time and the
end time of a time period
for which you want to have
all the voided purchases.
You call our API.
We give you back a list of
orders keyed by purchase token.
And then what you can
do with that is you
can use that to revoke
access to those orders.
Let me talk to you a
little bit about the three
different approaches that we've
seen developers use our data.
I'll go from really, really
simple to more complicated.
So the simplest way is
user purchases something
like 10,000 coins for $10.
We send you the voided
order, and what happens
is you claw back
exactly those 10,000
gems from the user's balance.
So the user is now--
their current balance
is minus 10,000.
But of course, there's many,
many games where you don't only
get 10,000 gems, but
you get 10,000 gems
plus one or two or maybe
three special characters.
So that's the second
case that we've seen,
is where developers say we don't
only claw back the 10,000 gems,
but also, we take
anything that we
added on to that-- some special
powers, special characters,
and we claw that back as well.
The third case that we've seen--
I guess the most complicated
case-- is where
you take snapshots
at the user state at
the moment of purchase.
So say this user bought
these 10,000 gems,
say, two weeks ago,
and with those 10,000
gems was able to get
two special characters
and go up three levels.
What we've seen
is developers who,
m when they get
the refunded order,
take the user back two weeks.
And then the user is
actually back three levels,
loses their two to three
special characters,
and loses the 10,000 gems.
So this worked really
well in stopping abuse.
And we also really believe
that this works really, really
well for good users.
So to gain access,
of course, you
need to have a developer account
registered with Google Play,
and you need to have a game
that accepts in-app purchases.
So if you want to
get started, this
is the point where I
would take a picture,
because we don't have this.
But there is a form
that you can fill out,
and then we'll whitelist
you for early access.
So John and I are really,
really excited to work with you
on this.
I think this is just the
start for us of getting a more
balanced economy
where we really try
to make the online experience
as fair and as balanced
as it is offline when you
buy your vacuum cleaner.
So going back to the goals
we had in the beginning--
we started to create a more
balanced in-app purchase
economy by allowing you
to claw back these items.
We're allowing access
to all developers.
It's early access now, but I'm
thinking maybe next quarter,
we'll open it up for everybody
if everything goes well.
And this creates
wins for all of us.
So we really see this
as an open discussion
between you, us, and our users.
So if you have any
questions, any suggestions
from your communities, feel
free to reach out to me, John.
Our email addresses will
be on the final slide.
So with that, I
actually would like
to invite two
developers on stage
to share their perspective
on fair play, which is going
to be really, really exciting.
So while we bring
up some chairs,
I'd like to invite
Emily Greer, who's
the co-founder and
CEO of Congregate,
and Regine Weiner, who's the
head of community and player
support for Space Ape.
And maybe we clap a little bit
while they put up the chairs.
[APPLAUSE]
However way you want
to do it works for me.
REGINE WEINER: Put on some
music, musical chairs?
DAVID RIPHAGEN: Yeah,
we'll do musical chairs.
Yeah.
EMILY GREER: What's the fairest
way to do this is the question.
DAVID RIPHAGEN: The
fairest way to do
this is I get all the chairs.
So Emily, maybe you
could start talking a bit
about your background
first, and then Regine,
and we'll dive into
some more questions.
EMILY GREER: So I'm, as I
mentioned, the co-founder
and CEO of Congregate.
If you're not familiar
with Congregate,
we started 10 years ago as
a browser game platform.
Kind of think YouTube for games.
Maybe not appropriate
at an Android event.
But an open platform
where any developer
can upload a browser game.
We add a lot of social features
and in-app monetization,
in which case we
were responsible,
like Google is now,
for the fraud, which
on PC can be probably more
intense than on mobile.
So that's an
interesting experience.
And then we continue
to have that platform.
But about three years
ago, we entered mobile
as a mobile publisher and have
published more than 25 games,
including-- some
of our recent hits
include Adventure Capitalist,
Animation Throwdown, which
is top 50 grossing on Android,
and today, a Peter Molyneux
game called The Trail, which
is very interesting, at lunch
today.
So you should check it out.
DAVID RIPHAGEN:
Congratulations on that.
Regine, you want to give a
little bit of background?
REGINE WEINER: So--
oh, wow, that's loud.
My background is a little
over 15 years in the game
industry, starting out
at companies like Disney,
making a trip through
Nickelodeon and Cartoon
Network along the way,
and finally ending
up at Space Ape Games in London
a little over two years ago.
My background is everything
from community support
to a little bit of development
to localization management
to project management.
So my background
has been varied,
and it's very much
player focused.
Our company is founded
on those principles.
And when you have
that, you have to be
focused on every
aspect of development.
as well as fair play.
DAVID RIPHAGEN: Great.
So Regine, let's stay with you.
Can you maybe talk a little
bit about your philosophy,
your company's philosophy,
around that playing
fair and level playing fields?
REGINE WEINER: So we are
a company full of gamers.
We were built on
building our own games
and making sure
that we enjoy them,
and then making sure that
our players enjoy them.
So when something doesn't
feel right in the game,
it's not going to feel
right to your players.
And because we as players know
that and play it ourselves,
we're actually able to
balance the economy.
We're able to make sure that if
there's someone who, as an edge
case, is able to exploit the
system, we can identify that,
because we're thinking
about doing it ourselves.
We always want the
advantage, and players always
want the advantage.
So I feel a few giggles
in the crowd on that one.
But it is one of
those things when
you're looking at
competitive gaming--
making sure that you're looking
at all the different ways
that your game can be played and
making sure that you understand
how it's going to be played
by the different users
that you have in your game.
We look at it from
a level playing
field, everyone from our
spenders to our non-spenders.
Because our spenders
wouldn't be in the game
if our non-spenders weren't
there to compete with.
Some of our non-spenders are
the most creative individuals
on the planet who are able to
compete against folks who are
spending thousands of dollars.
And that comes from a
very well-balanced game.
Given that information,
we actually
are very cognizant when you
have an advantage in the game
and you didn't buy it
and you didn't earn it.
So we have to make sure
that we can claw back
those different
items as well and we
make it a level playing field
for both of those audiences.
DAVID RIPHAGEN: Which aligns
really well with what we just
presented, I guess.
Emily, what about Congregant?
How do you guys do this?
EMILY GREER: One of our
core strategic principles
is building long-term
relationships.
And that includes developers,
players, partners, whoever.
And one of the core precedents,
or something-- core things,
base things that
you need to have
to have a long-term relationship
is you have to have trust
and build trust
over the long term.
And in a game and in
almost any situation,
it's impossible to build trust
if you don't have fairness.
There's other elements like
transparency and emotional
connection.
But fairness is the base
of the trust pyramid
and has to be--
with every decision
that you think about, you
have to think of fairness.
And you have to
think of-- you have
emotional responses to what's
fair to a particular player.
But as an important part of
community management and player
customer service is thinking
about what's fair broadly
and not just to an individual.
DAVID RIPHAGEN: So let me
ask you a question about it.
So you see fairness as
a key part of trust.
How do you make sure that
everybody in your company
is aligned on what's fair?
Because what's fair
for me might be
not unfair for somebody else
who's looking at the same case.
EMILY GREER: Right.
So a lot of this has been
trial and error and mistakes
over the years.
And interesting--
because we're a platform,
we get to see not
only our own mistakes.
We get to see the
mistakes of developers.
And so we get to see a
wide range of behavior.
And one of the things coming
out of various crises and things
that we've come as a
core principle is never
do anything for someone that
you wouldn't do for everybody,
or if you would do it
for a subset of people
that you wouldn't be OK
defending publicly on a forum,
on a live chat.
And that really helps clarify.
what's fair, is will you say it
publicly, will you defend it,
will all of us agree on it.
And especially in a
customer service situation,
that's the bedrock, is can
everybody stand behind this.
And then once you hit that
mark, then it's probably fair.
DAVID RIPHAGEN: Yeah.
I like that where you're saying
the key question for fairness
is how I would treat
one individual is
how we treat everybody.
And how is everybody going
to think about that, and how
does it all play together?
You can't make everybody happy.
That's completely impossible.
But there's a different
level of unhappiness
if with I didn't
get what I want,
but I see overall
that this is fair
versus I got screwed and
everybody got screwed.
JOHN MCGUIRE: Thanks for
sharing that perspective.
So we've announced this API
in this basement here today,
and it's really exciting but
I wanted to actually address
this question to Regine to talk
to you about your experiences
integrating the API.
Because I believe
you've had those.
And tell us what
it's like and if you
think it will be valuable.
REGINE WEINER: Oh, it's heaven.
You guys laugh, but
player experience
starts with being able
to provide it to them.
If you don't know
that this is happening
and you don't have a
way of dealing with it,
it is very difficult to look
your players in the face
and say that's not
happening in our game.
So having access to
the API and being
able to bring back and claw back
the items is very important.
The hardest part of integrating
this API is not the API.
It is deciding the
right way to remove
the items from your player so
that it's fair for everyone.
For example, if someone is
going to come in, use a gotcha,
not get what they want,
refund immediately,
and you're just going to
pull those gotcha items away
from them-- and, for example,
in our game, it's a duplicate,
but duplicates
give you resources.
So it's valuable to
your play style anyway.
But if you're going to actually
just pull those resources away
from them, you're not going
to have the same impact.
However, if you're going to claw
back their last crystal pulls,
they can't game the
system against you.
You just pull the top
last 10 that they did.
Half of the challenge
with implementing this
is having three different
games with Samurai Siege, Rival
Kingdoms, and
Transformers Earth Wars
and deciding how we
were going to approach
this in each of our games.
Because it's not about coins.
It's not about gems.
It's not about a
certain currency.
It's about the gotcha
items and the value of them
and taking that experience.
The other thing you
don't want to do
is you don't want to
beat up a good player.
Someone came in,
they double tapped,
they weren't paying attention
when they made a purchase.
OK.
It happens to somebody.
It's going to happen.
If that happens twice every
three months, it's acceptable.
EMILY GREER: That
was never really
your money, and that's
a different thing.
REGINE WEINER: Exactly.
It happens, so don't beat
your player up for that.
However, if someone goes
to a restaurant 38 times
and they eat their
meal 38 times,
they leave the restaurant, they
call their credit card company
and they get a refund
on that meal 38 times,
that is criminal.
It is not something
that you should
allow to continue to happen.
Beyond that, you
have other patrons
in that restaurant who are
paying for the same meal
and are paying for
the opportunity
to perhaps have
that steak that they
couldn't have because someone
else paid for it refunded.
So you need to make sure that
you have a level playing field
and that you're providing
them with a response that
is even and fair for everybody.
You refund.
It was more than twice.
This is how we handle it, guys.
I'm sorry that you've done that.
We removed the items from you.
So the hardest part was
deciding how you were going
to remove it from each game.
The API itself is
something that someone
with base level technology
skills can actually do.
If your tech team is around
and has availability,
you can hand it off to them, and
they'd have it done in an hour.
It's a batch process
on a nightly basis.
And if you hook it into
your system, it's great.
I would recommend
actually running it ad hoc
to begin with.
And the reason why I
say running it ad hoc
is you want to be able
to make sure that you're
removing the right things.
You want to make sure there's
no double purchases in there.
You want to make
sure-- by the way,
the API now checks for
that, so it's brilliant.
You want to make sure that
the players are actually
hearing this.
The other thing
which is more subtle
is once you start doing this,
your familiars, your cheers
gang, your MVPs, your VIPs
start talking to each other.
And it helps keep the
honest players honest.
The fraud guys are
going to do it forever.
But it helps keep-- it's
the lock on the door.
EMILY GREER: Yeah.
There's a group of
players who have
so much fun exploiting
things that they're always
going to exploit.
And then there's people
who are so honest,
they'll always be honest.
But the bell curve
are people who
will live up or down
to their situation.
So once fraud gets
going in a game,
it tends to spiral
out of control.
But the reverse is
possible with cleanup.
And we've seen that
happen on our platform
with different games
that started out
fine, got into terrible
abuse problems,
and then with hard work,
managed to get back
to a more even playing field.
REGINE WEINER: We have
incredible white hats
in our game.
When we started bringing all
of the fraud back in to check
and removing items
from them, they're
writing in and going, hey,
thank you for doing this.
I didn't realize that somebody
in my alliance was doing this,
and we have zero
tolerance for that.
And being thanked for that
was a very odd experience.
It was not the response
I was expecting to see.
And it's because you're
leveling the playing field,
and they no longer
feel like they're
playing against themselves.
JOHN MCGUIRE: That's
a really good point.
And I think the beauty and
the simplicity of this API
is that you get to take what
is a very simple process, which
is a refund, and apply it in
the right way to your game.
Because everybody
here has a game that's
different from each other.
And it would be hard to say
apply this one way, this one
method to revoking a currency.
And so you, I think, have
done a really great job
of applying this in
your game in a way that
makes sense for your community.
Emily, you are less familiar
with the API, I think.
And wanted to get your
initial feedback on it.
EMILY GREER: I'm only
familiar with our attempts
on web to do something similar.
But I'm really excited.
Basically, from the moment
that we came to mobile,
we were looking to figure out
if there was a way we could do
something like this,
and there wasn't.
And now I can't
tell you how excited
I am that it's available.
JOHN MCGUIRE: We're
excited for you.
DAVID RIPHAGEN: Maybe taking
a little bit step back
in the conversation, we were
talking about good users
versus bad users.
Right So there's always a
small percentage of bad users
that will always keep on trying
for different types of motives.
So how do you deal with those?
Do you try to identify
them, and then
what are the different
mechanisms that you use?
Emily, maybe you
want to go first.
EMILY GREER: Yeah.
Nothing is ever hack proof.
And you could work
on it forever.
How we organize our
time is to think
about what's the level of
impact of the cheating.
And that comes down-- it's
going to be very specific game
to game to game.
And a lot of it
comes down to are
you cheating your own
experience or are you
cheating other
people's experience.
The amount of fraud
and cheating that we'll
tolerate in a competitive
multiplayer game
is really, really, really low.
But in a game like
Adventure Capitalists,
if there's a hack where you
can change your phone and move
time forward, and
there's no leaderboards,
and there's no impact to
anybody but your own thrill
at progress, we'd
like to stop that,
but we're not going to put
as much effort into it.
It's not undermining the fun
of the game for other people.
So it's more situational how
much effort we'll put into it.
And there are
situations that are
in between-- like
leaderboards, for example,
in a single player game.
That is if you're
playing a game,
and you see nothing but hat
scores and the leaderboard.
It's not changing
most of your feeling,
but then it cheapens
your accomplishments.
So that's a lighter touch than
a PVP competitive multiplayer
game, but it's still
affecting your impact.
So then we'll-- especially
on Flash games on the web,
you can't stop it.
But what we've
done is we identify
what we think are
the cheater scores,
and we show cheater
leaderboards to cheaters,
and we show non-cheater
leaderboards to everybody else.
And cheaters keep cheating
and get their fun out of that.
And then people who aren't
cheaters get a true experience,
and that's how we manage
it in that situation.
But in other situations, we'll
be much more zero tolerance.
DAVID RIPHAGEN: So
you're telling me
that my high score that I
see all the time is actually
not a real high score, but I
fall into the cheater boards?
EMILY GREER: If you've
been cheating, yeah.
You already knew it was fake.
It then becomes a
competition of who's
better at cheating, which
is its own competition.
It's legitimate at
a certain level.
DAVID RIPHAGEN: Yeah.
But I guess in all seriousness,
what you're saying is cheating
is bad, but there's
various degrees of bad.
And when it impacts
my good users
to a certain extent when we talk
about wars of different clans
or groups together, that's
when it impacts good users.
EMILY GREER: And is it impacting
somebody else's progress?
That's much worse than
impacting somebody's sense
of achievement.
JOHN MCGUIRE: Regine, we were
talking about this earlier,
and you were talking
about some crafty ways
that you guys handled
cheaters and some of the ways
that you pooled them together.
I don't know if you want to
share some of your experiences
there.
REGINE WEINER: Very
similar to what she does.
So it's something that
apparently we all haven't
talked about, but I have a
feeling we've been removing
cheaters from leaderboards
for a very long time,
but showing it to
them so they continue
to think that they're on
it and not try and find
other ways to exploit issues.
But even beyond that,
even down to kids' games,
you have kids cursing in games.
And what you do is
you actually show them
the curse words to themselves
so they get a kick out of it,
but you don't show it to
the rest of your players,
because you're impacting the
majority of your player base.
And the same thing
goes with cheating.
If someone is
actually using scores
and they're continually
running up the leaderboard
and they look a little
bit out of whack,
you move them into a
different leaderboard.
But that's actually how we
engaged with you to begin with.
We monitor everything
in our economy.
And we found somebody who
is incredibly out of whack
is the only way to describe it.
We look at our numbers
every single week,
and we know how
many gems they have,
how many diamonds they have,
how many items they have,
how many items they should have.
And given this, it was
leaps and bounds higher than
where it should have been.
And it was one of those things
where 38 times-- and it was
way more than that-- he
had gone to the restaurant
and was able to
redeem the resources.
And it was because of the number
of times that they had done it
and how out of whack
the economy was
that we were able to
actually identify the user.
EMILY GREER: Do you ever
straight out ban users
from the game?
The API is about calling
back the rewards.
But do you do you full bans?
REGINE WEINER: There is a
finite limit to our generosity.
It's one of those things where
if you're an honest player
and you've done it a few
times and we've given you--
and by the way, we
do in-game warnings.
So it's not a
surprise to anybody.
You've got to be fair to them.
You've got to send them a
message saying-- I also give
them warning that I'm doing it.
So it's not that they've
logged into their account,
and all of a sudden, it's gone.
It's this is coming.
You've done it.
If you do this again,
you're not welcome anymore.
That kind of behavior
has been able to stop
the majority of these issues.
However, as with any
game, we have exploits.
And when we detect the
exploits because something
is out of bounds, even
better, we bounce them.
So they compete.
They do their-- it's one
of those things where
we impede their progress.
They're in there.
They're playing their PVP.
They defeat the base.
We detect the issue.
We boot them from the game.
They come back.
They do it again.
They get booted from the game.
They don't get the resources.
They don't get their gems.
They aren't able to gain
any advantage of it.
They aren't able to
continue their progress.
And for a while, it'll keep
the honest people honest.
However, it basically
serves as a honeypot.
Because then people
will start changing
the parameters to get just a
little bit of an advantage.
And those are the
people that we look
at when we say, OK, this
person is not a good person.
They are not there to play.
They are not there to enjoy it.
They're there to
exploit the systems
and exploit other players.
And that's when we ban.
JOHN MCGUIRE: I
think that's actually
a pretty good segue to the next
question, which is so we're
going to launch this API.
Everybody is going to sign up.
What would you advise other
developers to-- how should they
start thinking about fair play?
What is the one, two, three of--
EMILY GREER: Yeah.
There's pretty extreme examples
depending on the type of game.
Adventure Capitalist is so
different from any of the space
games and RTS that the level
to which you need to do things
is very different.
I think the principle of
what's the impact to others
and how you deal with it is
a good guiding principle.
But to get-- I don't
think I can give you
anything more detailed than
that, because it really
is about your game.
And different developers have
different tolerances and ways
they want to run their games.
Some developers, on principle,
are more libertarian,
and some are more authoritarian.
And ultimately, it's
your players' experience,
but it's your game.
And you can set
those ground rules,
and they would probably
implement the API differently.
JOHN MCGUIRE: Yeah.
I think-- just to give one
tip, what we've typically
done in our pilots is one to
two weeks of data analysis,
so just looking at
histograms of where
are the outliers of
people or countries
or levels where it really
looks like really, really bad.
And then I think
the second thing
you do is if you see
a lot of volume there,
how does it impact the others.
That's probably a good
way to think about it.
And then how would you
change your game economy
with the new information to
stop that egregious behavior.
REGINE WEINER: You might
also want to look at why.
For example, if you're
running a gotcha game
and your drop rates
are far too low,
it's time to look at
your gotcha rates.
If your gotcha rates
are far too low
and your refund
are far too high,
it's time to have
a conversation.
EMILY GREER: And that gets
back to actually trust
and to fairness.
If players don't trust you,
they're more likely to cheat.
They're also more
likely to cheat
if they don't trust each other.
But you are a factor
in the equation.
JOHN MCGUIRE: One of
the things that we've
touched on in a few of
these conversations has
been the role of community and
what that means for fair play.
And they go hand in
hand in some ways.
Because if you upset
your community,
people are going to leave and
potentially abandon your game.
Could you tell me how you think
about approaching community
and the role that it
plays when you consider
fair play in your games?
REGINE WEINER: You
want to take a first?
EMILY GREER: I guess.
What I would say is
our goal is community.
And fair play is a means to
creating a good community.
And that community
is what-- let's
say a game above a
pedestrian experience.
It makes it-- you
continue to play
a game-- you'll play a game only
so long just for it being fun.
You'll play a game so much
longer if you have friends
and if you have an emotional
connection to the game.
And that's something that
you get from community.
And so fairness is
a means to that end.
And that's how I think about it.
REGINE WEINER: So
we love our players.
I know you guys all say
you love your players.
We love our players.
They are welcome to come visit.
That's how transparent we are.
Specifically, the ways
we communicate with them
are a little bit different
than a normal developer.
Of course, we put our
release and patch notes out.
Of course, we put up a wiki.
Of course, we put
content and news feeds.
But beyond that, they have
access to us via band chats.
They have access via Twitch.
Our developers are
sitting in Facebook pages.
It's very strange, but
it's very manageable.
We have 20 to 30
million downloads.
The number keeps
growing, obviously.
And when you think
about it at that scale,
you say how can I attack this.
But you start with
your influencers,
and you bring them in, and you
make sure that they understand.
And they become your
voice, and you create
a relationship with them.
And then the trust builds.
And when trust is there,
believe it or not,
it's going to affect
your bottom line.
Because they're going
to play one game.
They're going to move
to your next game.
to your third game.
And you start building brand
affinity for your company,
not just for your games.
And they trust you.
So when something does go
horribly wrong-- as we all
know, as developers, they
do hourly, particularly
at lunch time, so I
feel for you today.
It's going to be a long night.
When you launch, having
that trust and that affinity
and the transparency to be
able to say, hey, listen, guys,
I acknowledge it, and
truth with your-- being
very truthful with your
players, it gives them
a little more breathing room
to say, hey, you know what?
You guys messed up.
I'm going to let it go.
I'm going to give you
a bye on this one.
But make sure you
take care of them.
Would you want to
have-- for example,
would you want to have an
item taken away from you?
Would you want to have
one player receiving
one bundle and another player
receiving a different type
of bundle for half the cost?
You wouldn't want that.
So when those
issues pop up, make
sure that you treat
players fairly.
And they'll trust you more
and they'll spend more,
because they trust you.
The other thing I will say is
we managed 24 by 7 support.
We do it in 11
different languages.
I've got 30 or so folks
who are embedded inside
of the game teams.
Each game team has a CCS lead
they feed back to the agents.
Our agents can talk to our
developers at any point.
So they don't feel like
they're having a conversation
with an anonymous developer.
And they do see the actions
are resulting in feedback
is being taken and implemented.
JOHN MCGUIRE: So Google is
a very data-driven company.
We're known for being
a data-driven company.
And one of the things we're
always into is measuring.
And so do you, in this community
and this trust aspect-- how
do you measure community
trust, or do you measure it?
Because I'm sure some developers
are in the audience thinking,
I could spend an
extra effort to go
through providing Twitch streams
and providing 24/7 support.
But how do you measure the
community trust or sentiment,
if you do?
REGINE WEINER: Player purchases,
retention, lifetime value.
JOHN MCGUIRE: And you can
draw direct correlations?
REGINE WEINER: Absolutely.
If you look at a lifetime
value of a company that
doesn't have support versus a
company that does have support,
you would find it
significantly higher.
Or community events,
live events in-game--
it shows that it's
active and alive
and they're willing
to stay for that.
EMILY GREER: Yeah.
I would say it's hard
to measure directly.
Retention is going
to be the best
measure by far--
long-term retention,
obviously not short-term.
And one of the things
that we like to look at
is momentum and look
at not pure retention,
but looking at
ratios of retention.
So what's your change
from D7 to D30?
What's your change
from D30 to D90?
Because different games
and different genres
are going to have
different baselines.
But that tells you a lot
about that experience.
So that's one way
of looking at it.
But that's still--
a lot of that is
going to come down to the game.
One thing is you know
it when you see it.
If you go into a
forum, you can tell
really quickly what the overall
sentiment in 10 minutes.
And now you can't
measure that and track it
in a really quick, clear way.
But we do do some tracking.
Our community management
do weekly summaries
and sometimes daily
summaries for developers
and talk about sentiment,
and we track that over time.
And then the other
thing that we do
is just tracking fraud rates
on purchases over time.
And that's not going to tell
you strength of community,
but it tells you when things
are going off the rails.
And you will see that
happen pretty quickly,
and you will see it
come back down as well.
That can be extremely dramatic.
REGINE WEINER: So we
do win-back rates.
Because players in the RTS genre
will burn out pretty quickly.
Nine months in, they'll
say I need a break.
Question is do they come
back a month and a half later
because they're invested
in your community,
they're invested in the game.
They're invested.
They've taken their break.
That's a very interesting
metric to look at.
Do they come back?
Do you reconnect with
them and say, hey,
your account is always
going to be here,
and we've put some
extra goodies in there?
If they come back, you
know you're doing right.
If they don't come back and
you have a very high percentage
of opens and they
just delete it,
that also is a very
interesting metric.
Because they saw it, they
opened it, they looked at it,
and they said nah.
DAVID RIPHAGEN: Yeah.
It's similar to long-term
retention with them
in the break.
I was wondering if there's any
questions from the audience.
We've still got some time.
You can shout them out or
use the microphone or both.
AUDIENCE: Have you ever
done any cohort analysis
on your high-value
consumers who've
actually gone through
this fraud return system?
REGINE WEINER: Yeah.
So here's the great news-- there
are multiple different ways
of implementing this.
You can put these
people into the negative
and make them re-earn back up.
And you do see them do that
if they're actively engaged.
And if you see, for example,
your golden cohort just refunds
his entire account, that guy is
never coming back regardless.
And it's really
interesting to do it,
because the other
thing it does is
it increases the trust
with the existing players
so they don't feel like they're
spending into a black hole.
Your MVPs are
talking to each other
every single day,
whether they're
talking through the systems
that you've provided,
or they're online, or
they're using BAND,
or they're on
Facebook, or they're
using any other mechanism.
But they are talking
to each other.
And as soon as one
person says, listen,
I refunded, and
this happened to me,
it sweeps through
your entire community.
And you know what?
The majority of the
people are like,
I'm glad they're
finally doing that.
That was so unfair
that this guy had
been doing that for six months.
And they started spending more.
It's been a nice bump.
EMILY GREER: Yeah.
And what I would say
is if you do something
that the player doesn't like but
seems fair, they will retain.
And we've seen that, because we
have so many games on our web
platform.
We've had games-- a
particular Chinese game that
had a very different idea
of community management
and customer service than
our players were expecting
went into a full-blown
crisis that resulted in,
I think, 70% of players
requesting refunds from us
in one month.
And we worked through-- that was
trial by fire, and a lot of us
10:00 PM phone calls
with translators
to try and work through it.
And what ended up happening is
we managed to save about half
of the players to the game,
and the rest of the players
we managed to save
to the platform.
They still didn't
trust the game,
but they trusted us in
terms of our attitude.
And that was five years ago.
And pretty much every
one of the big spenders
who we went through that with
is still an active spender
on the Congregate platform.
So they weren't
happy, but they were--
and we did claw
back a lot of stuff
and banned some from
the game, but kept them
on the platform,
complicated things.
But you can keep them.
And they're really,
really worth keeping.
The people who are most upset
are the people most worth
keeping.
REGINE WEINER: Passion.
EMILY GREER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I actually
have two questions
if you guys don't mind.
First question is how
transparent are you guys
with the community in terms of
when you guys are implementing
bans or showing evidence, or
is it just very mysterious,
like, hey, we've
caught these things?
How much communication do you
have down to the specifics?
REGINE WEINER: If I'm talking
to you and it's your account,
you know what you've done.
You don't know how I know,
but you know what you've done.
If I am talking to someone who's
trying to talk to me about you,
my relationship is with you.
My relationship is not
with your alliance leader.
So we do tell them that
this is what we're doing.
We do tell them that this is
how we're handling refunds.
It's on our FAQs.
It's in the public domain that
this is how we handle things
and that we do a deal
with it and address it.
However, I will never
discuss a player's account
with someone that's
not the player.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
And then the second
question I have is
whether with the clawback
API or just clawbacks
and bans in general, are there
common pitfalls in which you
guys have been overaggressive
or things to avoid?
REGINE WEINER: There is.
So make sure you're
logging everything.
That's the reality of the game.
You have to make sure
you log it so that you
know what you're taking away.
The other thing
is take a snapshot
before you take anything away
just in case you get it wrong.
And if you do get it wrong, mea
culpa and give them something
a little extra for your error.
Don't be shy about it,
and don't try and hide it.
The other thing I'll tell you is
that when you are clawing back
something, the player
has done something
they should not have done.
And if they are a good
player, they acknowledge it
and say, listen,
I got to refund.
I'm not entitled to this.
If they're a bad player
and they're like,
I have spent $4,500
with your company,
and I only refunded
570 of it-- you're
like, yeah, that's 570 errors.
You don't get to keep it.
And I do want to understand
why that person does it.
So it's helpful, and we're able
to gather feedback from it.
But in the end,
you've done something
your knew you shouldn't
have been doing.
You've been caught.
Let's deal with it that way.
DAVID RIPHAGEN: And maybe
to your first question--
so in our pilots, we've
seen different types
of communications.
So I've seen one developer who
went out, created a website,
had the community managers
talk to the community.
And every time to refund--
an order gets clawed back,
you actually have an
in-game message that's
blocking that's a pop up.
And it shows up in
your inbox as well.
We have other
developers who do it
more in the back
end, where they still
take the gems away
and send you an email.
So we've seen both.
It really depends on how close
you are with your community.
REGINE WEINER: Go in game.
Always do it in game.
I can't recommend it enough.
EMILY GREER: The other
thing is whatever
your communication
with a player,
expect that it will be copy
pasted to other players,
into forums, et cetera.
So again, being really, really
consistent on your policies.
And a lot of time, that means
getting everybody together
and whiteboarding out exactly
what you're going to do,
arguing it out, and getting
it straight so that you can
have that total consistency.
And if it's a major
error, especially
if you've made a mistake and
you're trying to make it right,
you want that totally
public and in your face.
Something that's
more individual--
yes, keep it individual.
But again, if you
would mind having
this email in your forums,
don't write that email.
REGINE WEINER: It's
really interesting.
We actually-- sorry.
Are we over time?
JOHN MCGUIRE: You can
finish your thought,
and then we're
going to finish up.
REGINE WEINER: All right.
So as everyone knows, we
had an outage or an issue
with an attack on
the East Coast,
and it's right during an event.
And when you're
doing live events,
you are feeling it
for the players.
Because they want to get in
there, and they want to play,
and it's a hard alliance event.
Well, what do you
do for your players?
Listen, I just lost 12
hours of this 36-hour
or this 48-hour event.
And it results in refunds.
Because they're like, listen.
I spent this money.
I couldn't use it.
I got in sporadically.
What you do in that instance
is you extend the events
if you can do it.
But if you can't,
you need to level
the playing field for
everybody who partook in it.
And you need to
be vocal about it.
You can't just say,
oh, well, your loss.
That's not the right way
to develop a relationship
with your audience,
your players.
DAVID RIPHAGEN: That seems like
a really good note to end on.
Regine, Emily, thank
you so much for joining.
[APPLAUSE]